let's talk about video games that we are
reviewing your games are not dead III
has happened it's done and dusted no
one's guys not every six weeks or
something but we still got video games
and you reviewed 1 yes it's from the
makers of limbo play dead called inside
eight and ten eight out of 10 yeah I
tell us about it's really good like it
is easily one of my favorite games of
the year I give it an 8 because I think
that you know when you did you play
limbo yes you played a couple times yeah
when I played limbo it I definitely like
I saw how cool it is and how like why
people love that game but they're also
parts of it that I felt were flawed yeah
I think that somewhere along the second
half is sort of lost itself it lost that
narrative feel that you had at the
beginning and sort of just got stuck in
this this rut of just completing puzzle
after puzzle I remember at the end of
that game feeling like oh I'm glad this
is exactly i enjoyed it but i was like
it was like 10 minutes over it's sort of
time yeah inside is much better than
that on it keeps its narrative cohesion
basically throughout the entire game but
there are parts of it where I still see
those flaws yeah um and I thought that
it was just enough to sort of break it a
little bit for me during the middle part
of inside and I guess your caveat while
we're starting here is because a lot of
people have been handing tetas attends
yeah yeah that's my caveat yeah it's I
am my score was on the low end of what's
been going around and yeah I believe a
lot of a lot of Ellis have been giving
it perfect score yeah which tends to
happen with smaller games I know they do
a little less so they tend to get
discount right to mark down a little bit
less as well right and yeah so I guess
let's speak to what works in this game
is it very similar to limbo looks like
environmental so like walking around not
super combat heavy right so it's the
gameplays essentially identical right
environmental puzzles you're walking
from left to right um you know you're
trying to get through this world but
other than that the sort of wrapping
around my gameplay is almost entirely
different okay like you know in limbo
the backgrounds were very vague like
they were white and grey and black you
didn't really see much in the background
yes to what
is presented was along the same plane
that you were walking and limp inside
rather the backgrounds are just like
beautifully detailed like they have all
sorts of motion going on in the
backgrounds like there are people
walking around there's things happening
things moving there's just these secrets
hidden back there that that give you a
little bit more of an idea of what's
happening in this world that was
probably honestly it's such a beautiful
game it is so gorgeous and just working
in that like taking the time to walk
slowly through these through these
levels and yeah looking into the
background was one of my favorite and
stuff happens in the background which
impact to you as well right yes like
I've seen departs we're like guys are
flashing flashlights I you guys look
like that yeah yeah one of my favorite
parts actually is during this section
where there's this sort of like pulsing
shock wave that comes every few seconds
and that pulsing shock wave will blow
parts of the background into the
foreground it can knock you off right
well term isn't like 2.5 d they are
using either like I mean like Rayman
Origins kinda as that a the Castlevania
3ds game rights always interesting yeah
it's very much like that 2.5 d um yeah
it I loved those sections of just you
know staring into the backgrounds and
seen things happening back there good
stuff what lengths are we talking about
and not gonna be reductive but just as a
sort of a general like it's pretty short
it's like three they took me like three
and a half hours ok so I'm through I
think Samantha limo yeah and then I
played it again because I wanted to go
through it again and see some of the
parts that I might have missed um and it
took me like an hour rise shine through
yeah Mikey Ghani fond memories of
playing limbo I only just finished it
first finally like four months ago
really it was I think it was free on
steam or something as it was like last
week again but I played it way back in
the day when around like Fez was out as
was braid and Limbo's in that first
group of indie games when we still used
India's like if they were actually
independent now it's kind of like a
catch-all term allah ya zama clean tail
end of that whole sort of sure and I
yeah I think I agree with Alex it was
kind of I got into that game for the
atmosphere and the storytelling like as
stark as the storytelling was but the
actual puzzles themselves became so they
keep became really difficult in the game
but I wasn't really looking for
difficulty I'm not averse difficulty in
any way but that game the momentum it
carried through the pacing had the first
half was just like yeah
stilted later on yeah and I think you'll
like inside then because the puzzles
don't really get difficult at all on
it's way more about the puzzles
interacting with the world and being
compliments to your exploration of the
world rather than actually just
complaining the puzzles so I've for most
of that game I thought it worked like
way better than limbo dead even cool
does it have that same sort of like
weirdly gruesome aspects as well like oh
yeah having to be sitting next to him
during one of those parts alright no
idea what was happening that was
actually the ending so let's not go into
that all but a sweet like during that
shockwave session then I was talking if
you get hit by the shockwave you
literally get blown to bits looks like
you're like your arms to get flung into
the foreground and yeah there are parts
where like blood just gets splattered
all over and yeah yeah it's I didn't
mention the ending though I do want to
talk about that as you know not spoiling
anything what did you guys think of
specifics yeah exactly what did you guys
think of limbo sending it was nice it
was like he was it was like I forlorn
and kind of like it was a I'm trying to
remember exactly the takeaway were
supposed to have so much but it was like
subtle and kind of like huh yeah okay
yeah but I didn't was like [ __ ] the
end of Bioshock win right um I thought I
thought lindos ending like it was nice
it was sort of abrupt you know yes
really frustrated entry lies was the
ending until it was the ending yeah so
insides is abrupt as well yeah am i
right yeah it's like I described it when
I when I saw it as like a roundhouse
kick of metaphor to the face um it's not
subtle at all okay incredibly abrupt and
it feels like this is one of my
negatives actually if I sort of like it
doesn't fit with the rest of it almost
like they're trying too hard at that
point um the more I thought about it the
more I sort of liked it yeah but I still
don't think it was the best way they
could have ended that game so yeah I've
got to stick the landing if you're going
to drag people through three our
narrative Leland you know explore of
game exactly it's at an xbox one right
now k mashed dead tomorrow marks
okay yes I'm there for pc then for a
week after july seventh apparently yeah
you played it on xbox one presumably
yeah we played on a PC yeah I having it
okay cool yeah I can imagine it's
beautiful on pc so yeah don't expect too
much in terms of controllers in like
that yeah thank you so much yeah thanks
for coming on thank you don't about
inside is one or more difficult games to
come on to the latvian talk about
because it's kind of want to keep it
vague as possible exactly a nineteen
ninety nine right now available on xbox
one will be on pc real soon as well for
I imagine the same time yeah cool